Captain America he's a hero gonna take
but Nazis down to zero that's the wrong
captain okay but I know they're making a
movie out of that I don't care never who
was posed a up my face but Captain
Planet movie I don't care why he's dead
anyway but I digress
this is the review my personal opinion
of the Captain America movie and just
off hand real quick impressions I liked
it
uh I was very impressed how they could
take something so phenomenally silly as
Captain America and make it entertaining
and not only entertaining but actually
you know you get invested and you like
the character you want to know what's
gonna happen all that good stuff um the
things that really stood out I'm sure
you pray you're a lot of people talk
about it but the effects on the American
kid when he's like you know a shrimp
wings like that tall very impressive
there's only like maybe one or two
moments I was like yeah that's a little
obvious even that's not that obvious
this was these were very very good
effects on making him look smaller I
mean really really impressive I say the
only downside to it is maybe his head is
a little too big as body a little too
small because it does sort of look like
a cartoon character sometimes but it
they match him up really well so that's
I'm sure a lot of people are gonna be
talking about that that is very very
very well handled um the best part the
best parts are in the first half of it
does that - reminds me a lot of Batman
Begins because the build-up and the
backstory and all that stuff is
surprisingly really good and like I said
you get into the main character and you
you really get on his side you know it's
the fight for the little guy the way
they incorporate the cheesy Captain
America costume is very very clever I
thought they really tied this and you
know even making the comic book out of
an stuff it's it's very very smart
the way they handle it I'm so shocked
how smart these comic book movies are
being treated it's I mean these are
comic-book movies I mean they're just
the silly
things that came out of like the 40s and
50s and whatever and they're really
treating with like Errol I respect okay
how can we make this plausible how can
we make this work so it's I'm really
impressed with what they've been turning
out um so first half very very good I
pretty much have no problems with it uh
the second half while not bad is not as
good again this sort of falls into the
Batman Begins territory where once he
becomes the hero in fact I'm her the
exact point where I suddenly said you
know I'm not caring as much and it's
because it becomes oddly enough very
rush because the first day of really
takes his time setting up these people
and then the second half he says I have
some ideas about the cause you may hands
it over yeah okay all of a sudden he's
just in my costume he's in that
silly-looking
you know helmet with the little painted
out wings and so which I'm sorry I still
can't take seriously every time I see it
I kept so the costume they handed in
before with just the helmet and the
little goggles and the star has it that
was more plausible so it was hard for me
to take that seriously but what happened
after that point I think they felt maybe
that all right we've had a lot of
buildup a lot of this let's just throw
in the action really fast and that is
what happens it's like when the action
actually comes as decent action but it's
really quick it's genuine he's in the
costume it's just like boom there he is
a kind of like the movie I review the
1994 movie review where it's just like
he's in the costume they just twice it
at you it's like whoa okay um and the
actions are works that way too in the
second half where it's just okay if
there's a train coming let's go there on
the train it's they're just you know
they're just they're what we gonna do
knock on the front door yes
there they go knock down the front door
and it was so rushed
which really jolts you because it's like
oh okay well the first half really took
its time and does just be thrown in like
that really sort of shakes you up um so
that bother me but again that's not it's
not a huge problem because it that's the
comic book party you know here's the
fighting here is him throwing the shield
the shield's awesome by the way they do
a lot with it um you know here's him
flipping around doing all this stuff
here's
and red skull you know saying their
cheesy one-liners um so but for this
idea I mean again this is like Ninja
Turtles like really you're gonna make a
movie out of this they did a pretty good
job I was really shocked how invested I
was getting into it um like I said as
soon as he becomes the superhero the
actual superhero with the helmet that
goes over the eyes and stuff and I wanna
say it gets sloppy or lazy that's not it
I think I know what they were thinking
they're probably thinking okay we took
her time now we've really need to speed
up the action and get the people that
Rock'em Sock'em that they want um so
Hugo Weaving as the bad guy is Hugo
Weaving you know he's sure like the new
Tim Curry like you just know whatever
he's gonna do it's gonna be you know
over the top it's gonna be a logo fee
but it's gonna be cool you know he's
gonna be pretty cool doing it um he's a
bit of a boring villain not Hugo Weaving
himself just Red Skull himself I thought
was sort of doll I'm he's just he wants
to be super he wants to take over the
world I haven't seen that you know so
there's a charm to him you know there's
because it is Hugo Weaving and he's got
those permanent you know Satan eyebrows
so um yeah so for for mom like I enjoyed
it I thought it was fun I don't know if
it follows the comics I think it does I
know they had the little psych Hitler
thing everyone's been telling me that by
the way it's like they have the styler
in there I'm like yeah okay so it's not
as funny as the 1990 review but it's
pretty cool uh so yeah in in terms of
comics I think it follows that okay I
was really shocked how like I said I got
how much I got into these characters
people who wouldn't like it I suppose it
may be the comic book fans that like
think they would um you know I'm sure
they're gonna have problems with the way
the costume looks and you know it could
be corny or there was a lot there's a
lot of cornball and here as handled very
in a very fun way particularly when he
becomes sort of this you know big icon
the celebrity they they really poke fun
at that and
do a good job with it um and there
finally now instead of just doing you
know little hints of the Avengers they
just show the Avengers trailer at the
end so you don't see much but you know
day there they are okay that's you know
it's made now at least you know it's
shot so that that's nice so yeah I'm not
sure who would I mean I'm sure it's
people dislike it um where people who
really want to get invested and really
like wow god the agony the pain of
Captain America and stuff it's there in
the first half it served glossed over in
the second so people might have a
problem with that but it's decent I mean
it's a decent you know serve on the same
level of Thor and to play a little
better than Thor but it's sort of on
that same level like oh that was a
decent film you know I'm not fantastic
but look at the subject material it's
pretty impressive they could pull this
off so um yeah that's my two cents on it
keeping it too much else to say I'm glad
I saw I'd have a lot of good cheesy fun
and that's about it
talk to you later